now then the prime minister has had a
face-to-face audience with her majesty
the queen
for the first time since lockdowns in
the uk began
i've just been talking to your sexually
safe
health poor man he came for privy
council oh
let's speak to our political
correspondent joe pike about that talk
about the conversation in a moment or
two what we gleaned from that but just
the fact this has taken place
these personal meetings face-to-face
meetings have been on hold for what 15
months or so
they have indeed they've been taking
place via a phone for most that time
although of course boris johnson
was at that g7 dinner hosted by the
queen at the eden project in cornwall
and these meetings are pretty
intriguing they've obviously happened
throughout the queen's reign
winston churchill was the first of her
14 prime ministers to take part in these
uh weekly audiences usually 20 minutes
in length they are held in private there
is no recording no minutes taken no
notes
so actually we never know what they say
but that is the very reason
they are intriguing and both uh these
people have been through a pretty
uh difficult year not just the prime
minister admitted
to hospital with covert but the death of
the queen's
husband of course and there was that uh
key moment last
april when the queen addressed the
nation
saying we will be with our friends again
we will be with our families again we
will meet again
and then not long after that same sunday
evening boris johnson was
admitted to hospital there has been some
speculation since
that boris johnson put off going
to get medical help because he didn't
want to upstage that key moment that was
really not just of national significance
but international significance
and what about the uh conversation you
say it's unusual that
um they they release any images at all
or any moving images
at all of the meetings so what did we
glean from their discussions
well she referred to matt hancock for
health secretary because he was at a
privy council
meeting we understand with the queen
early today privy councillors are
advisers to the sovereign
mainly uh senior politicians and she
described matt hancock as
the poor secretary of state uh full
health perhaps because of the difficult
year he has had not necessarily in
reference
to the uh recent reports that the prime
minister
privately described him as expletive
hopeless but it is interesting to see a
picture of this meeting because
it is something that has been um
displayed
and dramatized helen mirren famously uh
played her majesty in the audience that
play that went to the west end and
broadway depicting these meetings
written by peter morgan who then went on
to
write the little known series the crown